SONAM THUNDEN: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name Sonam Thunden.
And on behalf of Google
Mindfulness and Buddhism--
Buddhist at Google
Groups, I would
like to welcome our two
guests, Khenpo Tsultrim
Lodro and Professor David
Presti to Google today.
[APPLAUSE]
Khenpo Tsultrim Lodro,
or Khenchen Rinpoche,
has emerged as one of the most
prominent Tibetan Buddhist
scholars living today.
He oversees the education
of about 40,000 monks,
nuns, and lay students at Larung
Gar in Eastern Tibet, which
is perhaps the largest monastic
community in the world.
What I found fascinating
was that more than half
of those who come to study
there are female Buddhist
practitioners.
Khenchen Rinpoche has
also worked tirelessly
to preserve Tibetan culture.
He has started libraries
and built schools.
Khenpo is also a widely
published author.
His books range
from commentaries
on classic Buddhist
philosophical texts
to a book about inspiring
advice to both monastic and lay
audiences.
I had the fortune of
meeting Khenchen Rinpoche
last year here at Google.
At that time, we talked about
developing Google Translate
for the Tibetan language.
I have a day job in
finance, but I also
moonlight as the unofficial
in-house Tibetan translator
whenever necessary.
One of the challenges that
Google Translate is facing
is the lack of
high-quality data.
I discovered that
Khenpo has co-authored
several Tibetan-Chinese-English
dictionaries that primarily
focuses on building a collection
of modern Tibetan terms.
This is the first
dictionary of its kind.
So when we met with
Khenpo last year,
he had promised to
provide us data,
and today, he has done so.
So we are very grateful.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
He is also well-known for his
compassion towards animals.
He is a dominant ethical voice
among the Buddhist religious
teachers when it comes to
promoting vegetarianism.
He advocates a vegetarian
diet, and puts great effort
into life saving and the
life release of animals
procured to be killed.
He sponsors annual
summer life releases
to save vast numbers of lives.
Khenchen Rinpoche has rescued
more than 100 million lives
so far.
And for that work,
he's sometimes
known as the Life
Release Khenpo.
Based on Buddhist values
and ethical principles,
he's establishing a
vegetarianism movement,
animal rights movement, which
is extraordinary for someone
from Tibet, where
meat has historically
been a main staple of the diet.
Professor David Presti is a
neurobiologist, psychologist,
and cognitive scientist at
the University of California,
Berkeley, where he
has taught since 1991.
Between 1990 and
2000, he has worked
as a clinical psychologist
in the treatment of addiction
and of post-traumatic
stress disorder
at the Department of Veterans
Affairs Medical Center
in San Francisco.
He holds doctorates in
molecular biology, biophysics,
and clinical psychology.
Since 2004, he has been teaching
neuroscience to the Tibetan
monks and nuns in India, part
of a dialogue between science
and religion initiated
by the Dalai Lama.
Professor Presti's
expertise include
human neurobiology
and neurochemistry,
the effects of drugs on
the brain and the mind,
the treatment of addiction,
and the scientific study
of mind and consciousness.
Khenchen Rinpoche
has, for a long time,
had a great interest
in modern science,
including physics,
biology, and neuroscience.
In our world, there
is often a divide
between science and
religion or spirituality,
but rather than distancing
himself from science,
Khenchen Rinpoche
has immersed himself
in the study of
science, and often draws
on science to help elucidate
important Buddhist concepts,
at times breathing new life
into ancient Buddhist concepts.
However, Khenchen
Rinpoche also seems
to be very well-aware
of the fact
that science still has
not understood everything,
and in fact may still
have some catching up
to do with Buddhist science.
So today, we have
to have a fruitful
dialogue between these two great
minds on the topic of Buddhism
and science and where this
conversation between Buddhists
and scientists is
going, and what
needs to be done in order to
move this conversation forward.
So without further ado, please
welcome Khenpo Tsultrim Lodro
and Professor David Presti.
[APPLAUSE]
And I can't help but offer this
traditional Tibetan welcome
khatas to both Professor Presti
and Khenpo Tsultrim Lodro,
[TIBETAN]
MALE SPEAKER 1: OK.
So given the Chinese-speaking
audience here,
I would like to
give an introduction
or welcome speech for
Khenchen Rinpoche in Chinese.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
[APPLAUSE]
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo
is very happy
to have this chance to engage
in a dialogue with such
an expert scientist as yourself.
DAVID PRESTI: And I
too am greatly honored
to engage in this dialogue with
a scholar such as yourself who
also has a very strong
interest in science,
and to making connections
between the Buddhist tradition
and the worldview and
tradition of science.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: I'm of
the view that there
are many points of contact
between Buddhism and science.
Even though they have their
own respective topics or fields
of research, there is much
commonality between the two.
For example, in
terms of the methods
they go about researching their
respective topics of research,
and the principles that
underpin the way they
go about their research.
DAVID PRESTI: That
also is my impression.
And I feel that this
conversation that
has been happening in various
different ways between Buddhism
and science over the
last several decades--
I mean, it may go back even
further, more than 100 years,
but more robustly over
the last several decades--
has been a very healthy
thing for introducing
some innovative new
ideas in science,
and I hope a healthy
thing also for Buddhism.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Is the main
topic of our conversation
today that of consciousness.
DAVID PRESTI: Is?
INTERPRETER: Is it?
Could it be?
DAVID PRESTI: I hope so.
[LAUGHTER]
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo
is of the opinion
that research into consciousness
is research into humans.
And whatever method we use
to conduct this research,
it is research
that is not solely
relevant to religious
realms, but has
a relevance beyond this.
DAVID PRESTI: I absolutely
agree with that.
I feel like investigations
of consciousness
are perhaps the most interesting
question in all of science--
there are many interesting
questions-- because really
consciousness is about
who we are as humans
and how we experience
our connection
with the rest of reality.
And what could be more important
and more interesting than that,
than to try to better
understand who we are
and how we're connected with
what we think reality is.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo has heard
that some scientists disregard
the idea of consciousness,
and have even said
that it's not necessary to have
this word in the dictionary.
What would your
thoughts on this be?
DAVID PRESTI: That's a
pretty extreme perspective.
The truth is that all
we know, everything
that we experience is
by way of our awareness,
is by way of our capacity
to have what we're calling
consciousness here, have a
connection with what we're
calling consciousness.
So it really is
all that we know,
and anything that we
conclude about the world
is coming through this
vehicle of our consciousness.
So to dismiss it is not really
a very tenable position,
although it can
often be dismissed
as being something that
is beyond our capacity
to effectively study
scientifically,
that it's hard to design
experiments that will really
give us useful information
on what consciousness is
and where it comes from.
And so therefore,
it's perhaps better
to work on other things
that may be more directly
leading to some kind of new
innovation or new measurable
phenomena in nature,
or something like that.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo
started off by saying
that currently among scientists,
the mind or consciousness is
considered to
exist in the brain,
or as a function of the brain,
that consciousness or mind
is explained as a brain process.
But he's heard of
an experiment where
mice, laboratory mice
whose-- the memory component
of their brain was removed.
So previously, they
had been trained
to find their way around a maze.
And then the memory component
of their brain was removed,
and yet they still knew how
to find their way around
without having this component
of their brain there.
How would you-- what would you
think about this experiment?
Have you heard of it?
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID PRESTI: Yeah,
I would have-- no, I
don't know that experiment
particularly, specifically.
I know that there are
experiments of that nature that
suggest that whatever--
if memory in the brain,
which is the
conventional viewpoint
in contemporary
neuroscience, then
it's going to be
distributed in a way
that it makes it very
difficult to selectively remove
some part of the
brain or inactivate
some part of the brain and be
assured that you have erased
every aspect of that memory.
So it could be that
that specific experiment
may be addressable in that way.
However, that being said, the
question about where does mind
come from and how do mind
and consciousness relate
to brain physiology is a
deeply mysterious thing.
And although no one would argue
that the brain is necessary
as-- the brain and our
body and our nervous system
and all of this is necessary
for our experience of awareness
as we understand it, it
may not be the only way
that that awareness
can be maintained or be
manifest in some
way, that there may
be aspects of what we're calling
mind and consciousness that
go beyond the body in ways that
contemporary neuroscience has
not even begun to address.
And this is a very-- this
is a very interesting area
for future-- hopefully
present and future discussion.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: So for example with
the experiences of suffering
and compassion, scientists
explain these as operating
as the same kind of electro
current in the mind.
And even though you could
say that maybe compassion
and suffering as feelings
have maybe some similarities,
in actual fact we understand
them to be very different.
So do you think
that there will be
another way of going
about explaining this
or researching this?
DAVID PRESTI:
Well, from-- again,
from the perspective of
contemporary neuroscience,
it would-- the framework
for which we currently
have to understand experiential
phenomena like compassion
and suffering is by way
of physiological processes
in our body and in our brain.
And so that-- the
paradigm that's
used in contemporary
science is just
to keep pushing that
as far as we can go.
And at this point, what's
known about things-- what's
known about the
neuroscience, the underlying
physiological processes
of emotions like suffering
and compassion, is very limited.
And so everybody
thinks we're only
at the beginning of being
able to better understand
what's going on inside the
brain and inside the body when
these things happen.
And those directions should
certainly be pursued.
What would also
be interesting is
whether you have other
ideas about ways that
could be investigated using
the methods of science--
and by the methods
of science, I simply
mean asking questions
and looking for answers
and trying to make
sense of observations
and looking for
patterns, not being
stuck in one particular
theoretical way of describing
something-- whether you have
other ideas about how one might
usefully investigate
things like compassion
and suffering that
might be helpful.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo feels that
if the current methods that
are used to investigate emotions
like suffering and compassion
are not improved significantly,
then it is quite difficult--
it will be quite difficult
for us to make advancements
into this kind of research.
However, if these methods
were improved significantly,
then it may be possible to.
DAVID PRESTI: Yeah.
Yeah.
I would agree with that.
INTERPRETER: Yeah.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
DAVID PRESTI: What
really interests
me very much about the
conversation that we're
having and the larger
conversation between science
and Buddhism is
ways that-- I feel
like the most interesting
thing for science
is when we are forced
to completely shift
our paradigm in some way,
our worldview, because
of what we're observing.
And this really has happened
only a very small number
of times over the entire
history of science,
like when people like
Copernicus realized
it's better to
think of the earth
as not the center
of the universe,
that other things are
configuring in a way that
puts the earth in the
periphery somewhere, that
led to a whole new
revolution in science.
And Einstein's ideas about
relativity and quantum physics
and evolution, these were
big changes in the way
that people thought
about reality.
And I'm thinking that
we may be on the verge
of similar big changes in the
way of thinking about mind
and consciousness, and that this
conversation that is happening
can bring in some
really new ideas
into the study of
mind and consciousness
that have not really
been part of science
as we've done it so far.
And I'm wondering what
you think of that.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo
feels that, in order
to contribute-- if we're
talking about contributing
new ideas and new methods to a
new paradigm shift in this way,
that the ways we go about
currently researching matter
are probably not sufficient.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Material matter.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: So
for example, if we
are talking about images
or visual information,
we can see this with our eyes.
However, sounds
are not something
we can see with our eyes.
We need our ears
to perceive these.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo feels
that actually we don't need
to make things so complicated.
If we're talking about
understanding the mind,
probably using the mind
to understand itself
is the best way.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: What would
you say about this?
DAVID PRESTI: I think that
sounds pretty reasonable.
[LAUGHTER]
INTERPRETER:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
DAVID PRESTI: Yeah.
The kind of place
that science is at
is that we have a set of
methodologies and a paradigm
that nobody can argue with.
It works really well.
Even Khenpos have iPhones.
You know, it's like
everybody has a smartphone,
everybody has a computer.
These things came from the
way that we study matter
and understand matter.
So but is that enough to get
us to the next level of insight
about the nature of mind?
I don't think so.
And it'll only be
part of the picture.
And some of the ideas that
you bring from your tradition
and history I think will be
very valuable for taking us
to the next step.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo feels
that the current methods that
are used for
researching the mind,
if the idea is to proceed
on this foundation
and keep going with
these kind of methods
to research the mind, we're
never going to get to a point
where we have a
paradigm breakthrough.
So the paradigm
breakthroughs that
have been seen in
biology or that
have been seen in physics,
that in terms of understanding
the mind, say, in psychology,
that using the current methods
are just not going to produce
any kind of breakthrough.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo just agreed
with what you said before,
that essentially what we
need is a complete paradigm
shift in our approach
to this in order
to make a breakthrough about--
or in regards to researching
and understanding the mind.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Google being a
place full of very inquisitive
minds certainly has a lot of
opportunities for questions
from the audience.
And so to prepare
for your talk, we've
asked Google at large,
all around the world,
to submit questions.
And we will also take some live
questions from the audience,
as well.
But to-- as inquiring
minds want to know,
I thought maybe we could
take this opportunity
to move into this format.
So the first question
that we have here is
can artificial intelligence
ever achieve sentience?
If consciousness can enter
a body, why not a machine?
DAVID PRESTI: Well--
[LAUGHTER]
For me, that's an easy
question to answer because it's
an empirical question for the
future-- at least to start
the answer-- you can
back off for a minute
and say, we can never know
anything about consciousness
except for our own
consciousness, at some level,
that the only thing I
am absolutely sure of
is that I'm conscious and the
only thing you're sure of,
perhaps, is you're conscious.
However, if we're willing
to take for granted
that maybe we can share
a belief that we all
have some kind of consciousness,
then whether a machine can
become conscious is a
question for the future.
Certainly, AI will continue to
be more and more elaborated.
We will certainly continue to
have endlessly more intelligent
machines.
Whether they will ever develop
any kind of awareness--
if I had to bet one way or
the other at this point,
I would say no, because
biology, I believe,
is way more complicated
than anything
we're likely to build in
even the distant future.
I think a lot of questions about
the likelihood of sentience
in constructed
systems underestimate
the complexity of biology.
You know, biology has
been evolving on Earth
for billions of years.
Nervous systems and brains have
been developing for hundreds
of millions of years.
The level of complexity
inside a single cell
is beyond our capacity to
even grasp, let alone describe
at this point.
And so the idea that
we're going to somehow map
every cell in the brain and
build a silicon replica of that
and it's going to have
the capacity to upload
consciousness into
it and anything
like that, it just ain't
going to happen anytime soon,
and maybe never.
But it's an interesting
empirical question,
and we will continue to
pursue that avenue certainly.
And so I'm excited to see
where it takes us just
in the next few decades,
let alone thousands of years
from now if we
continue to do this.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo also
feels that this would probably
be quite unlikely at the moment,
or unlikely in the future given
that even though
Buddhism regards
the-- consciousness as something
that is beyond the body,
nevertheless for it to exist
on the base of another thing,
such as for it to exist on
the base of a human body
or anything-- for
example, a flower-- there
are many, many infinitely
complex conditions that
would need to be in
place for this to happen.
However, one possibility he
could imagine in the future
is, if a sufficiently
sophisticated device were
designed that could hook
up a person to a computer
and, through a
process of meditation,
a person were able to
transfer their consciousness
to the machine.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID PRESTI: I like that.
INTERPRETER:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
DAVID PRESTI: I'm always
looking forward to your answer.
MALE SPEAKER 2: And Rinpoche
has demonstrated his prescience,
for the next question
similarly has
to do with the transference of
consciousness or mind stream
not necessarily from
human to machine,
but the question is, is science
doing anything at this point
to understand the possibility
of the mind stream
coming into this life
from a previous life,
or incarnating from this life
into the next life after death.
Is anything happening in
the scientific community
to understand this
question, and what
is the understanding of this
question from the Buddhist
standpoint?
DAVID PRESTI: Within the
scientific community,
a little is being
done, but very little.
There are a small
number of researchers
around the world that
are interested in trying
to empirically document
stories that small children
spontaneously tell of detailed
information of someone else's
life.
And some of those stories
are very well-documented,
and really check
out to the extent
that they can be investigated.
There have been some very
prominent researchers
historically-- Ian Stevenson,
a professor at the University
of Virginia, now
deceased, and his protege
and now the leader
of the research there
in this area, Jim Tucker--
so there is an attempt
to really do good
science around this,
but it's a very small number
of people and it's not-- it's
mostly not known about.
And to the extent that
people have heard about it,
they really don't know
what to think of it,
and primarily because we
have no way to explain it.
We have no way to
account for this
in our current biophysical
understanding of the body
and the mind and all of this.
And I think this is one of
the most interesting areas
to pursue for the future,
to look for things like this
that we can't explain.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo
has also paid attention
to the research that's
being done at UVA,
and in Tibet has himself
conducted research
into past and future lives.
And what he found
through his research
was exactly the
same as that which
has been found in other research
that has been undertaken.
So for example, children
of-- young children
of two years of age being able
to tell stories of their past
lives without any
other prompting.
And these recollections
would endure
to a period of when they were
eight or nine years of age,
and then slowly they
would forget these things.
And Khenpo says that this is
the same all over the world,
that this is how people
recollect their past lives
all over the world.
They remember them
when they're young,
then they gradually
forget the details.
And the fact that this is
observable and in many cases
all over the world
indicates that this
is, in fact, a true phenomenon.
It's a real phenomenon, and
it should be taken seriously.
Khenpo notes that
Professor Stevenson,
that before he died he said
that one of his greatest regrets
was that his research had not
made an influence on mainstream
science.
Khenpo thinks that, in general,
the very strict, rigorous
approach that science takes
to its research is good,
it's appropriate, but
there are some areas
in which it could really do
well to open its mind a little.
DAVID PRESTI: I
agree completely.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question mostly for David
about cognitive scientists
and neuroscientists
who comment on this
question in the public.
A lot of them are telling us
very forcefully and repeatedly
that there is definitely
no such thing as free will,
and there is certainly no
such thing as consciousness.
My question for you
is, how pervasive
is this line of thinking
among cognitive scientists?
Please tell me they
don't all think this.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID PRESTI: I can assure you
they don't all think that way.
And I think it, in part,
boils down to the difficulty
with trying to design good
experimental strategies
to address these questions.
You know, something like
free will very quickly
spirals into a convoluted morass
of being hard to kind of know
how to grasp this.
Consciousness, I believe,
is much more tenable.
And I also believe that these
are the kinds of things that
motivate us to look for
phenomena which are clearly
relevant to things
like consciousness,
but that are currently outside
of the explanatory framework,
the previous thing
that we just talked
about in the sense
of past life memories
being an example of that.
Because if that were to be
better studied empirically,
it would force us
to expand the way
we're trying to explain
things, and it truly
would be a paradigm-shifting
expansion of our understanding
of reality.
If that gets at
what you're saying.
AUDIENCE: I thank
you also for coming.
And I have a two-part question,
the first-- mostly for David,
again.
The first is, you alluded
to some research that
suggests a possibility of
consciousness not originating
from outside the brain, but
possibly having some existence
outside the brain.
And I was wondering if you could
indicate what research you--
if I understood that
correctly-- what research
you're alluding to there.
And the second part
is, research that I--
I don't know too
much about this,
but I've heard of research
like Dr. Rupert Sheldrake's
morphic resonance,
which I'm aware
has been roundly discredited.
But I've not found a really
solid discreditation.
So I was wondering what you
thought of that, if you're
aware of that, as well.
DAVID PRESTI: Yeah,
well I-- first of all,
I think it's-- those
are excellent questions
and comments, and it's important
to appreciate that what we know
from contemporary physical
science and neuroscience is
that our bodies and our brains
and our nervous system are
certainly necessary for
our capacity to function
in the world, including
to be consciously aware,
and that whether that's the
whole story is completely
unknown.
It's an assumption.
It's only an assumption
that it is the whole story.
And it's very much analogous
to the old image of,
well, if all you
have is a television
and you're watching
what's on the TV,
then you just assume that
it's all coming from that box.
And of course, that's
not even-- of course
the box is necessary for the
construction of those images,
but everything is coming
from somewhere else.
And there's no way we
can say that that's not
the case with us, that we're not
simply some kind of receivers
that are connected
up with a larger
matrix of interconnectivity
that we don't have any capacity
to investigate at this point.
You can't-- that hypothesis is
consistent with everything we
can say from our science.
And so to entertain that as
a working hypothesis is not
at all unreasonable.
In fact, it's very reasonable.
And that is what
really underlies
things like morphic
resonance and stuff
like that, that
there is some kind
of profound interconnectivity
that is linking things together
in ways that we just
don't have a grasp of yet.
So I'm completely open to that.
So at that point, then,
you want to say, OK,
what kinds of empirical data
can you find in support of that.
And the past life stream
stuff is certainly
one aspect of that.
If there is some way that
information about one's
being can get communicated
after they die,
and that suggests that
something is going on that's
beyond the body.
Other kinds of
phenomena that suggest
some kind of interconnection
between people over distances
or time spaces
that are not-- that
wouldn't normally be explicable,
there's plenty of evidence
that things like that happen.
But it's not taken seriously
by mainstream science.
So those are things
that I feel push us
in the direction of
needing to at least look
at some kind of expanded
way of describing things.
I'm the first to admit I have
no idea really what's going on.
I just-- the only
thing that I know
is that we have a paradigm
that works really well.
It gives us the internet and
smartphones and all of that.
But is it the whole story?
Well, I doubt it.
It's never been the case
that our scientific way
of describing things
at some moment in time
is somehow the whole story.
That's a lot to translate.
Sorry about that.
[LAUGHTER]
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: In terms of
particularly in relation
to past and future lives,
within the realm of Buddhism
there is a great amount of
evidence concerning this.
So not just only the
recollections and memories
of people, but
also, in many cases,
people are able to
prove they've got
physical evidence of
actions and activities
that they have conducted
in previous lives, too.
So from a Buddhist
point of view,
from a religious
point of view, this
is-- there is a lot of evidence.
However, this is
something that remains
very difficult for science
to research seriously
using its current methods.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: So for example
in Tibetan Buddhism,
in the case of
treasure revealers
who discover treasures that
were planted in previous lives,
this is precisely
the kind of activity
that involves treasure
revealers tapping into knowledge
from previous lives.
So this is one type
of evidence that
is regarded as valid from
a religious point of view.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo feels
that if the existence
of past and future lives
was able to be understood
and therefore able to be
accepted, that this would open
up a great scope for
doing further research
into other aspects or
other aspects of the mind
existing beyond the body.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: For
example, in the--
in terms of treasure
revealing, Khenpo
has seen with his own
eyes-- and not just himself,
but many have seen with
their own eyes-- for example,
Khenpo's own teacher actually
go about revealing treasures,
so recovering treasures from
lakes and from other places,
as well, revealing--
taking out vessels or items
and opening them and finding
within them pieces of paper
on which symbols were written.
And this kind of
action is very much
one that is based on
a consciousness that
transcends the body and
connects past lifetimes
to the present lifetime.
So Khenpo feels that
this is something,
if properly
investigated, would yield
a lot of useful information.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo feels that
a research methodology that
relies primarily on
researching the brain
to understand consciousness is
an extremely narrow and limited
approach from the point
of view that we still
don't understand the brain.
So if we're using an organ that
we don't yet fully understand
to understand this
kind of thing,
then it seems from the outset
that it's quite limited.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Another example
is near-death experiences,
which is something that Khenpo
has also done a bit of research
into, as well, where people
who have such an experience,
their consciousness leaves
their body for a period of time
and, during the period
that it has left the body,
does various things and is
effective in various ways.
This is something that there
is quite clear-- or there's
a lot of evidence for, and
that is possible to understand
quite clearly.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Do
you think-- what's
your opinion about
near-death experience?
Do you think it is
something that's true?
DAVID PRESTI: Yes.
And I also believe
that that is one
of the other very powerful
places where we can investigate
empirically things that are
happening with consciousness
that are currently
not explicable.
If it can be
empirically verified
by what people are saying,
that their awareness has
left their body for
a period of time
and experienced this or that
and then comes back and then
that's empirically verified.
And there are people who are
attempting to do that-- again,
a very small number--
and it's good science.
It's just so hard to do
these kinds of projects
because scientists
like to set up things
that they can reproduce in some
nice, neat way in a laboratory.
You can't do that with
a near-death experience,
you know?
They're very-- they
have their own agenda.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, I just
want to say that I'm
very optimistic about the
future of this encounter
between these
traditions, and where
this might lead for expanded
ways of appreciating
the intricate activity
of all beings.
KHENPO TSULTRIM LODRO:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
INTERPRETER: Khenpo
also feels that,
for the future collaboration
between Buddhist researchers
and practitioners between--
in terms of collaborations
between them and
scientists, he also
feels extremely optimistic
about the potential here.
[APPLAUSE]